your analysis of economic historical
events is based on five forces and I'd
really like to start this conversation
by getting you to just quickly summarize
those five forces okay uh just to give
you a little bit of background I um I'm
a global macro investor and what I
learned through my experiences is some
of the times that I was surprised is
because things didn't happen in my
lifetime but I found out they happened
in the past in history so the three big
forces that really drew me attention to
studying the Rises and declines of
Reserve currencies and and Empires where
first the amount of debt creation and
the amount of money creation and the
whole impact of debt and money on the
economy the magnitudes are unprecedented
except you have to go back to the 30 to
45 period and happened many times in
history the second is the amount of
internal uh conflict particularly the
development
of populism on both extreme due to the
largest wealth and values gaps that we
have and a populist is an individual who
will fight and win at all cost including
the system so I never saw that before
and I needed to go back I knew it
existed in the 30 to 45 period needed to
go back and study it the third force of
course is the great power conflict
internationally you know we had uh our
world order began in 1945 at the end of
World War II then there's a new way of
doing things the United States was the
dominant world power had a 50% of world
GDP 80% of the world's money gold was
money then and uh had a monopoly so
every they determin how things would go
pretty much and then of course now we
have the great power conflicts and so on
uh so those three things last time they
happened 1940 30 to 45 period I wanted
to go study them in the past in doing
that study over the last 500 years I
have fabulous research team that can do
this uh in doing it over the 500 years I
saw that uh two other things popped um
uh maybe more important comparably
important uh was um acts of nature
droughts floods and
pandemics so climate became a big issue
and of course climate is a big force of
our time because no matter what is done
or not done it's going to be very costly
so it's certainly an economic issue and
then number five was technology the the
changes in technology so those five
forces I uh saw and and I realized how
they interrelate with each other to
create this Big Arc and so it's like
watching the movie happen over the same
time over and over again and it's a
great framework for looking at history